ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس
بين الحين والاخر تقوم روسيا بهجوم موسعا
على اهداف غير تقليديه ككيف على سبيل
المثال ما الهدف من توسيع الهجمات بين
الحين والاخر
اذا اصبحت استراتيجيه اساسيه تستهدف
القدره على الصمود لما يجري على خطوط
التماس وعلى المعارك ان كان في الشرق شمال
شرق والشرق وحتى في منطقه الجنوب النمط هو
سباق بين ما يمكن اصلاحها من البنى
التحتيه وبالتالي اعاده تدميله للوصول الى
مرحله عدم القدره على الاصلاح ايضا النمط
المده بين كل مرحله من القصب واخرى يتعلق
مباشره ايضا بما تملك روسيا من ضمن
ترسنتها ان كان من ال- ال- المسيرات
الايرانيه او غيرها وان كان من الصواريخ
البالستيه
استهداف منطقه انجلز بشكل متكرر حيث
القاعده العسكريه الروسيه ايضا الى ماذا
الرساله من وراء ذلك
المره الثانيه خلال شهر هذا يعطي نمط معين
ان يمكن نقل المعركه الى الارض الروسيه
واخبار الراي العام الروسي ان الماء ان
الحرب ليست بعيده هي قد تاتي الى الابواب
والى الداخل الروسي 2 رمزيه الهدف منطقه
قاعده عسكريه لقاذفات الاستراتيجيه
وبالتالي بعيده جدا يعني القدره على قصفها
وبالتالي هي كما يقال بالانجليزيه الريسي
بروسيتي التعامل بالمثل
وارسال نمط جديد ذكره فدى عند المسيرات
التي استعملت هي من صنع سوفيتي اوكراني
معدله وليست امريكيه كي لا تحرج على
امريكيين في القصف داخل الروسي يعني اثرت
الى رمزيه الهدف هل ينسحب ذلك ايضا على
سقوط صاروخ داخل الاراضي الروسيه
لبلاروسيا واقع جديد في ده هناك استعداد
كما يقال لامكانيه فتح الجبهه هناك ضغط
روسي على الرئيس البيلاروسي لفتح الجبهه
ولكن اليوم الخطا وارد
شراينا منذ شهر تقريبا كيف سقط صاروخ 300
اوكراني ضمن الاراضي البولنديه وبدات
التوتر يصعد حتى قال الرئيس انه صاروخ
اوكراني ليس صاروخ روسي اليوم قد يكون هو
سبب لفتح باب مشكل مع بين بين روسيا
واوكرانيا او الاستعداد لخلق هذه المشكله
لمرحله قد تاتي لمرحله ما بعد الشتاء طيب
ما مدى الاستعدادات البلاسيه لذلك خاصه ان
انا كنا نسمع عن تدريبات
بين الجانب البلا الروسي والجانب الروسي
في بيلاروسيا فداء حتى الان ليس هناك من
وحده قتاليه كبيره جاهزه بكل ابعادها يعني
من الطيران الى الصواريخ الى المستشفيات
الميدانيه الى المدرعات كي تقاتل على جبهه
او حدود مشتركه بين اوكرانيا وبين ااا
بيلاروسيا تقارب ماء 1080 كم هذا ليس
متوفر حاليا ولكنه احتمال في المستقبل اذا
اكتملت المنظومه العسكريه للدخول قطع
الطريق انه اللوجستي من بولندا وبالتالي
اعاده تطبيق كيف وكاننا نعود الى المرحله
الاولى ولكن مع اهداف اقل شكرا لكل اصح
لنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا
من بيروت